pour déchirer à déchirer viellard vous
connaissez mes vielles sentiment pas
déchaîné méchanceté tout investi le hall
des sports du lamentin plein à craquer
pour accueillir la messe des cendres qui
vient ici clôturer trois jours de
retraite spirituelle
on se plaît pas entrer dans le carême
simplement c'est à dire c'est la porte
d'entrée pour aller vers pâques pour les
40 jours et le chrétien fait pénitence
et il faut des gestes il faut des
symboles on a l'habitude de ces 12 et
ses modes comme le baptême i follow 1 et
mais il faut la parole c'est le symbole
va toujours avec la parole alors ce qui
fait l'essence en signe de pénitence
sans signe de conversion voilà qu'on
veut ou à tourner vers dieu pour les
fidèles sur la marque donc l'entrée en
carême un important moment de foi pour
les catholiques la messe des sens et
votre maître que nous sommes pêcheurs et
que nous sommes poussés ou tout
simplement si l'entrée en carême où on
doit fortifiée plus à payer
et puis se convertir ces temps de
conversion le terrain pour celles à la
pénitence de poule quand même c'est la
joie
sur les 110 depuis halo ou est avec
jésus quand j'avais 20 ans c'était le
mercredi des soldes c'était le cas
aujourd'hui je suis à la cinquantaine le
mercredi que ça n'a plus rien à voir
avec le carnaval et c'est ma période de
préparation
les cendres pourront être donnés jusqu'à
dimanche dans les différentes paroisses
de la martinique